hi there steve kaufman
today i want to talk about how to choose
a language to learn
now if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notification
if you follow this on podcasts
uh apple podcasts or spotify or
elsewhere
um
please leave a review it's always
appreciated
now
how to choose
the language to learn well first of all
you know this is to me a very
interesting subject because
most people who are learning a language
didn't really choose that language
i start with the situation in canada
where it's because canada has two
official languages
if you are in the french language system
you're going to learn english and if
you're in the english language school
system you're going to learn french
how motivated are the kids to learn did
they choose those languages
i think that in reality probably the
kids in the french school system are
more motivated to learn english than
vice versa because english is so much
more important in the north american
context than french
kids in the french and the english
language school system are
not tremendously motivated to learn
french which is a big reason why they
don't do very well
if you live in the united states
probably spanish is the language that
you're
most often asked to learn so the first
thing i would say is that if the
language learner has the opportunity to
choose the language to learn
there's a greater likelihood that they
will do well so that's number one so i
have always said or have often said that
it's unfortunate that let's say in
canada kids are told to learn french
that it's their obligation to learn
french somehow because it's an official
language
if they had the choice to learn whatever
language they wanted and if they were
then able to learn that language they
will subsequently always be able to
learn french because once you have
learned one language you have the
confidence you know how to do it
and your brain is a little more flexible
you're going to find it easier to learn
another language by and large so
i think
in our schools we would be better to
give the kids a choice now it used to be
that you know if a school doesn't have
like you can't give the kids the choice
of any of ten languages because then we
would need to have teachers of each of
those 10 languages and the schools can't
afford to carry teachers of all these
different languages that's no longer a
factor because
nowadays there are so many language
learning resources available on the web
including teachers online including
audio books and movies and you name it
and link of course that if the schools
had the teachers who were knowledgeable
about how to learn languages
via the internet that's all they would
need they wouldn't need to have specific
teachers for each language they can even
find those teachers online so
it would be great if in schools people
were given the choice now assuming we
have the choice which language should we
learn now the next so my whole thing
about language learning is get rid of
the obligations so the first sort of
obligation is the school system says you
shall learn english or french or spanish
or whatever the case might be
give people choice give the kids choice
second of all very often uh parents of
immigrants
are very keen that their children should
learn the call it ancestral language
sometimes called the heritage language
i'm also against that if that works
if the parents speak with the kids
around the house in that language and
the kids pick it up that's great or if
grandparents live together with the kids
and they speak the language and they
pick it up that's great but if that's
not the situation uh i'm not
tremendously in favor of sending the
kids to chinese school or russian school
or you know persian school uh to learn
that ancestral language unless the kids
are interested uh it may be that the kid
whose family was chinese speaking might
be more interested in spanish or some
other language and so always i favor the
idea of letting people choose the
language that they are most interested
in so then how do you choose which
language to learn people are going to be
more successful if they're motivated so
you know if you feel a tremendous
interest in the culture of a particular
country
if you have relatives
because you come from a certain country
you want to communicate with those
relatives
uh if you saw a movie if you're
interested in anime in other words
wherever you have a motivation
that's the language you should learn
even if it theoretically is harder
it doesn't matter you should go for the
language you're most motivated to learn
because that motivation will carry you
through the difficulties
and as i've said in other videos you
know the initial period is you're
learning a few you know new words you're
able to understand some things but the
path to sort of genuine comfortable
communication in the language you know
is a long one and therefore you need to
have this this motivation to sustain you
so i would very much
favor learning a language you're very
interested in over one that you think
might be more useful because once you've
learned one language it's easier to
learn another language so go for the one
that you're likely to succeed in and
you're more likely to succeed in the
language that you're very motivated to
learn
okay
um other considerations obviously if you
know
related languages if you know a related
language if you know spanish you might
want to go for
spanish or
french or portuguese or italian because
obviously if you have success again
that's going to encourage you to
continue or at the very least to stay
with it so
i have tended to want to do that i
learned russian then i went for uh i
think czech and then ukrainian and then
polish and because i knew spanish i
wanted to learn portuguese and italian
the so-called low-hanging fruit so
obviously we like to push where there's
the least resistance so
one consideration is your degree of
motivation obviously and i think that's
that's paramount but another
consideration is how easy is it going to
be for you to learn that language now if
you are not interested in the language
even if theoretically it's easier you're
going to have a tough time learning it
because i repeat in my experience
motivation is the biggest consideration
in choosing a language
obviously the things that make it easier
could also include the writing system
you really have to commit to learn a
language where the writing system is
different
it's a lot tougher because reading is
such a big part of language learning and
when we're dealing with a different
writing system even if we learn what the
characters represent and so forth it's
always harder for the brain
to to read in a different script at
least that's been my experience
uh because if i've spent 75 years not 75
but if i've spent most of you know of my
life reading in the latin alphabet my
brain is very used to the latin alphabet
no matter how well i can read in chinese
or korean or japanese or russian i will
never feel as comfortable in those
alphabets as i do in my own alphabet and
the same is true in reverse if you are a
japanese reader you know speaker or a
persian speaker
chinese or russian then you're always
going to be more comfortable i think in
in the language in the writing system
that you've spent most of your life uh
reading it
so
motivation is number one but then how
difficult is it going to be and so there
is this tendency to want to go for
something that's
you know
um
easier
now i should one final thing of course
and and this is probably what ends up
being the main reason why people learn a
given language you know in the real
world
is because it's useful
so you know english tends to be the
language that's
uh studied the most around the world
because it's perceived to be the most
useful
now there are people who say chinese is
going to be very useful because they're
it's such a huge country with a
you know huge economy
so that's
you know if you consider that to be
useful but if you are
if you want to work in germany or you
want to work in japan or you want to
work in brazil
then there are reasons why in those
scenarios those languages or in
other similar situations would be the
most useful so usefulness obviously is a
big factor
but if if you find that that if you are
convinced that that language is going to
be useful but you're not genuinely
motivated to learn it because you don't
like it
you may find it difficult so in an ideal
scenario you can combine
the useful
with
things that motivate you if you can
combine usefulness
and and and pleasure
you have the best of both worlds and
particularly if the language is
you know if you're uh english-speaking
person learning french or spanish it's
written in the same alphabet a lot of
the vocabulary is in common
actually
if you are combining pleasure with use
utility and it's not too difficult you
should have an easy time of it but
right now i'm learning persian and
arabic i've learned chinese i've learned
russian i've learned
japanese so
if you are motivated enough you will
overcome all the other obstacles so i
hope that's helpful in how to choose the
language to study and to learn thanks
for listening